salut avant de commencer cette nouvelle
true story oui je dis trou story c'est
la marque de fabrique de ces true story
je vais vous parler de ce que j'ai mis
en place cette semaine j'ai fait un test
sur la vidéo de lundi sur la vidéo
d'hier j'ai commencé la vidéo en dix ans
derrière ce titre put à cliquer se cache
etc etc
c'était un vrai test pour voir les
réactions parce que vous vous dites j'ai
du mal avec le mot [ __ ] à cliquer je les
fais seulement deux fois et hier j'ai eu
énormément de commentaires vous invite à
regarder les commentaires d'hier
disons que c'était agaçant que je dise
que c'est un titre plus tactique parce
que c'est pas un titre plus tactique et
ça devient saoulant que je fasse ça deux
fois seulement et je suis d'accord que
c'est agaçant d'entendre ce mot tout le
temps pour tout et n'importe quoi mais
moi je comme je lis tous vos
commentaires je le dis tout le temps
pour tout et n'importe quoi ce qui
pourrait me faire même passé une envie
de lire les commentaires des fois je
vous avoue il m'en faut plus mais ça ne
met pas dans une bonne énergie quoi il
ya eu une inversion à un commentaire
d'hier qui explique oui c'est embêtant
que je fasse des petites [ __ ] à cliquer
comme le titre d'hier qui est un titre
put à cliquer et la vidéo traite du fait
de mettre son mental à zéro donc de le
mettre ko par extension et parle de
méditation donc le mot méditation c'est
tout le thème de la vidéo
bref je reviendrai plus jamais là dessus
j'ai fait mon test j'ai vu ce qui en
ressortaient et pour moi ma conclusion
c'est que ce mot aujourd'hui n'est plus
du tout maîtrisée et ce qu'ils utilisent
à tort et à travers se rendent pas
compte à quel point ça peut être agaçant
en fait quand on lit les commentaires et
que ça peut un peu passé l'envi moi ça
ne la passe pas mais je comprends qu'ils
aient d'autres youtuber qui a arrêté en
fait avec ça et c'est pas une leçon que
je suis en train de faire j'avais juste
envie de de partager un sentiment en
fait mais aujourd'hui c'est une journée
trop story alors génériques
l'histoire que je vais vous raconter
vraiment arrivée et depuis le temps que
je la raconte à mes amis ils m'ont dit
d'en faire une vidéo alors quand j'étais
un petit peu plus jeune j'ai fait des
tests chez l'ophtalmo régulièrement et
il y avait ma marraine aussi avec qui
j'étais parti en vacances qui avait
demandé à ma mère de s'inquiéter un peu
de mes yeux parce qu'elle trouvait que
je lisais mal les panneaux je crois que
ça en était resté là à l'époque que
j'avais dit non je lis très bien et moi
je savais que j'avais un problème pour
lire parfois c'était un petit peu
compliqué en fait depuis toujours je
sens bien que je vois pas de loin avec
cet oeil là et que je vois pas trop de
près et c'est elle mais j'avais un petit
peu noyé le poisson
et puis vers l'adolescence il y avait un
système qui existait ou a vanté 16 ans
tu pouvais aller consulter un ophtalmo
gratuitement à un espèce de dépistage
des yeux j'en sais rien d'ailleurs je
sais pas vraiment si c'est un des
hameaux ou ou un médecin un peu c'est
comme la médecine du travail un truc un
petit peu plus généraliste je ne me
souviens plus très bien de ça tout ce
que je me souviens c'est qu'il m'a fait
le test d'acuité visuelle
c'est le test de monnoyer pour voir si
on voit bien de long et de loin moi ça
va pas très bien et je le sais depuis
toujours il faut savoir que je voulais
pas porter de lunettes jamais voulu que
l'aîné je veux pas porter de lunettes
donc quand on est arrivé là bas on était
face au bureau j'ai bien pris le temps
de mémoriser toutes les premières lignes
du test de monnayer simplement en
utilisant les moyens mnémotechniques que
j'avais déjà ma disposition
jean je sais que ça commence par mrt
parce que j'allais le mot morte dans ma
tête le band reggae tout ça va faire une
écharpe pour vf us etc etc
sur les six premières lignes parce que
vraiment de loin c'est un peu compliqué
mais il ya quelque chose que j'arrive à
distinguer c'est celle à la forme la
tâche donc j'essaye si le médecin me
faisait voir le 4e ou 5e et je prenais
le temps de répondre
et depuis j'ai bien pris sont aussi
d'insérer quelques petites erreurs pour
être crédible et donc j'ai eu 9 et 10 ou
de 8 et 9 je me suis un peu de ça en
voir j'ai eu deux très bons résultats à
mes yeux et j'ai pas eu de lunettes et
le temps passe le temps passe le temps
passe vite la médecine du travail j'ai
fait la même chose et ce qui est génial
c'est que le test de monoï et ils ne
changent pas vous dit pas de faire
pareil parce qu'au final en fait ya un
point qui se règlent pas mais et c'est
assez rigolo de se dire bah ils changent
pas en fait donc les gens peuvent
tricher mais en fait à cette époque là
j'avais pas compris que ça servait à
rien de tricher pour sa santé en fait
c'est complètement stupide
bon j'ai pas dit que j'étais toujours un
grand malin et la plus ça va quand même
plus ça pose problème ce faire que quand
je regarde comme le voir des spectacles
je suis souvent au fond de la salle
je vois comme si comme si j'avais de
l'eau ou des larmes dans les yeux je
vois troubles alors si je fais ça je ne
vois que d'aller loin mais si je fais ça
je vois que dalle de près nous on va
dire ya toujours un des deux qui
compense et donc je suis enfin aller
chez l'ophtalmo il ya quelques jours
donc j'ai fait les vrais tests toumert
là il ya plus possibilité tricher parce
que tout est automatique sans voix des
trucs sur être aux projecteurs à
distance donc tu peux pas anticiper en
fait ce qu'il ya donc les résultats sont
que je suis hypermétropes de l'oeil
droit
myope de l'oeil gauche et astigmate des
deux yeux c'est à dire que des deux yeux
j'ai du mal avec les lits les contours
ce genre de choses et ça ça me fatigue
beaucoup le cerveau en fait pour
analyser et rectifier tout ça en
permanence donc ça y est je vais aller
me faire faire des lunettes c'est ça en
fait le résultat ce que je voulais pas
j'allais faire alors bon après je les
mettrais bien quand je voudrais en fait
c'est surtout aussi quand je monte etc
je me fatigue les yeux ou quand je vais
voir un spectacle mais je vais avoir des
lunettes quoi je suis dégoûté en fait en
plus je trouve ça classe les lunettes
il ya plein de personnes que je connais
qui ont des lunettes et c'est plutôt
stylée tu vois mais moi je sais pas
pourquoi ça passe pas les bons
hypermétropes myope et astigmate stayart
de bientôt la chaîne a va s'appeler
daredevil mentalisme
voilà ça me faisait rire de vous
raconter cette trou story parce que ça
me permet de révéler ce petit côté un
petit peu escroc d'avoir toute sa vie a
pris tout le test en entier vous vouliez
un moyen mnémotechnique pour pouvoir à
chaque fois faire maintenant je vais
super bon petit le moi tout va bien au
final sera servi à rien puisque
maintenant je veux faire les minettes en
face il ya un truc quand même rigolo
c'est que ces clubs tels mots que je
suis allé voir et valley en tout cas
c'est pas une dégénérescence c'est
quelque chose que vous avez toujours eu
ses pales l'oeil qui a fatigué avec le
temps donc vous avez toujours été comme
ça c'est assez drôle qu'il a fallu
attendre de plus de 30 ans pour vous en
rendre compte
tu m'étonnes merci beaucoup d'avoir
regardé cette vidéo j'espère que ça vous
a plu si c'est le cas n'oubliez pas de
mettre des pains pouce en l'air en fait
on a une règle qu'on va réinstaurer
c'est tout les 10000 pouce en l'air que
je refais une trop storrer comme ça ça
évite d'en avoir trop souvent c'est
quand même pas le concept de la chaîne
mais comme ça aussi quand c'est beaucoup
demander genre en fait non demain vous
aurez une vidéo un petit peu surprenante
que j'ai faits graves
ça quelqu'un qui fabrique des énigmes en
fait je viens à vous donner le thème de
la vidéo de demain
allez portez vous bien passé un bon
week-end le mental blog c'est toujours
une vidéo par jour pendant un an du 1er
janvier au 31 décembre on est déjà au
mois de décembre c'est juste où ça
rendez vous demain à 17 heures non à 11
heures on sera samedi on s'en sort quand
même ciao
de fait seul
là
[Musique]
à